senator ted cruz is back in texas
admitting his whirlwind trip to cancun
was a mistake when a nice storm comes
rolling in
and folks might soon be shivering you
could be in the office government
helping out your constituents or you
could go
down to mexico wait a minute sift the
drink on the sunny shore
um you seem good at your job on twitter
so
you can go down to mexico we're gathered
here for an impeachment
the president's lacking innocence so we
owe it to all the citizens
to move forward with all the witnesses
next week is recess or we could go
down to mexico it's valentine's week and
don't you know
i look good at my job on twitter so
perhaps i'll head down to mexico
as a pandemic starts to rage and we make
a vaccine hooray
let's take our data to the fda we'll
take a look in a few weeks okay
for real here's a question for
determining
if the people you elect to lead are
maybe not that great at governing
do people prefer this to your currency
increasingly then maybe go
down to mexico sip a drink on the sunny
shore
when a nickel is worth less than doge
perhaps it's time to go to mexico